you
welcome everybody to bahaha my friends
those two it's wayne just bagged up
we're just talking we were just talking
like normal people and all of a sudden
and weird and I well is he separates us
from other podcast because I act like
it's go time all the time please that's
the secret of my success a me a free
divers your voice and you look with the
Cowardly Lion now I like the way I know
that look I like that look awful haircut
that you have it my god this is special
you're talking right into a microphone
let me just give you it let me give you
a hint welcome to the show how about
that just look an option is tonight show
and shows him the now music show
business all right I know he's
dismantling the mic now on a majestic
body massager to run away from you this
is a weird well big news Sean's in the
studio yes lovely wife mariela's in the
studio I was just weird who's middle
near phone she's done with this podcast
already a right and Aaron's the right
and then Wayne Federman our guest thank
you've seen him from all over the place
turning my phone I'm putting on an
airplane even though we're in a studio
he probably likes you they don't have
her meal male together yeah understand
what I say a facedown baby that's how
you do I had like a moment with Wayne at
the improv I'm still having about it
because he was talking about I guy ever
ever date a comic and he said yeah I was
ten years is good it was like yeah two
people drowning can't save each other
and then winds like that's not at all
what I said you made a depressing it
wasn't a depressed lately so please
[ __ ] on me are you talking about let
me say thank you for doing that because
let's store he wants them when did you
say to people drowning whole each other
is the worst possible scenario not
everything's poetic man you're like no
is fine it was a very good relationship
don't touch with a girl
something it's sad nothing was a Jeff
Buckley album okay then the right yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'm not mistaken he sang
a cover of hallelujah yeah yeah yeah if
i'm not mistaken this is gonna be crazy
as off time do I have any computer with
me go do I have any no not a real device
and your photos facedown phone and it's
on airplane mode / studio I believe the
Jeff Buckley's die drowning yeah drought
he drowned and the last thing he sang
was heard singing as he went into the
river was whole lotta love by Led
Zeppelin now that might be a completely
different person we googled it tweet
Rick garran check that thang or 70 more
like a lot of low blah blah blah that's
impossible because he's here right now
good song oh yeah um really good song
what did he didn't write it who's the
girl undergoing yeah Glenn Lenny Cohen
what are they going one of their delani
Cohen let them come with a guy who's
great and then people who are also great
cover his songs like with the Nina
Simone one Suzanne Suzanne Suzanne smoke
come around yeah but please the new your
small versions oh yeah but you need some
over is unbelievable yes great but they
see he's not a singer really he's more
Leonard Cohen yeah yeah singer no I know
but he's not like my dad went to go see
him in concert like 60s or 70s or
something and he was like yeah it was
the worst concert it's like you played
for an hour and they just like he like
did he really didn't want to do it yeah
me and Mary I want to go see I'm a huge
van Morrison fan of a horse you do say
van Halen then Morrison okay yeah been
wild the movie even 10 yet they wanted
to actually rise of time we will do see
Van Morrison and right he's kind of like
David Lee Roth
and he plays like it out and he was
yelling at his bandits voice was
pitch-perfect but he was yelling at that
he was such a curmudgeon his band was
he's like hurry up how he's yelling at
the bed after playing their solos come
on hurry up just keep going and then he
would go into his amazing voice oh he
did have a good voice yeah I think he
was one of those guys if i'm not
mistaken by the way the first musical
guest on late night with jimmy fallon
was Van Morrison oh and he also you I
think he's one of those guys that was
upset that the songs that became popular
I you know today like brown eyed girls
yeah exactly you'll sing it yeah he
doesn't sing it or even once a moon
dance Moondance yeah like all of those
songs he don't think he likes and
there's other stuff that he's so
passionate about that yeah the only fan
fans love and I think he's just bitter
about who's technically the first
hipster if you think about it cuz
they're like the things that got popular
I don't know those a bad joke okay
thanks no I thought you were making a
valid point wait wait really sunk that
in turn but I'm not only gonna do this
so at some point when a joke doesn't
work you look down Wayne like looked up
and like watch the joke not working to
fly into the ether shut up Dan to add to
it you got it I got it I got this just
glad that I'm sorry Jen I'm just kissing
I was looking as that he looks like this
is like sting this looks like more like
a rock I'm kissing the guys as damaged
as I don't like stink no no it's a great
album girl a good album cover was it but
the thing is I don't want to talk about
the sound too much but I feel like this
is 31 years of stand-up 31 years your
whole life my whole life how when were
you born can I 78 I'm 37 oh ok so this
is you're already a kid when I started
yeah but it's like it starts with me I'm
very happy about doing stand-up and then
by the end I'm like what do I look like
you're in the street I'm in the street
what am I what have you done so is it is
it material for the past 30 well you
know it is okay so is it more than 11
CDs or wanted to see call three CDs oh
it is called okay great that's what i
call 32 but it's yes it's more than one
CD oh that's great that's how it starts
out in New York and then I go to New to
LAX I've talked about it I'm up
but is it not here maybe the chronicles
of Federman that's it so I just I had
all of these arc on archival like a lot
of material some of their own VHS tape
some of it on so you mean a shame again
or now dow this is just up from the idea
seven this a bit yeah i can't really do
an 84 olympic joke active don't worry
you could just go horribly wrong
according stuff yeah the guy who just
refused to put his eighties reverences
damn know this bit about Quicksilver is
killing i do do like a enough disk wanna
go a bit about the World Book
Encyclopedia right what you might not
know about now he knows that was the
whole encyclopedia britannica whoa book
yeah yeah we at all yeah we're all
booked at my house cross yeah yeah cuz
that's a thing so it was a man now
that's what you did school report oh
yeah that's right those are great I had
to do a thing about rainbows when I was
in second grade and I had to use the
encyclopedia yeah but now the kids don't
even know what that is well it's because
its one millionth of the internet is an
entire encyclopedia absolutely so Rea
but I feel like there was more when they
had encyclopedias don't you feel like
there was more um now if they go online
couldn't they just easily get wrong
information you know I'm saying with
Wikipedia now and everything like that
they could get some very wrong
information the encyclopedias were like
edited and edited again and they were
vetted and they were like they were
trustworthy material but it was also
people deciding what was important
within that book right where's Wikipedia
is just like right here hey he's a bunch
of facts yeah yeah yeah I like it better
now I like it back even though obviously
you anyone can edit Wikipedia yeah
speaking of Wikipedia yeah Buckley st.
whole lotta love when you in the river
oh my genius is in the state was a weird
thing to bring up dry pod can all
fairness the awesome of the just a weird
thing to bring up the way right I am
find out I knew how many people died in
that fire on this comedy podcast but to
be honest Wayne wrote his Wikipedia page
so that's your sure oh my god it's
pretty good so it was him okay that's
pretty great a while once in a while
Oh 31 years what's the word I'm 31 years
what's the worst experience of a read on
stage oh boy that's a good question let
me think let me think cuz there was I
mean there was a horrific show early on
in my career but i'm trying to think
there's anything i would say losing on
Star Search was the worst experience i
had on stage losing on Star Search you
mean but how far you get into it but our
set my first first set you aust on up
yeah yeah but you mrs. ha what year was
this was a t56 eighties and that's
really that's interesting that that's
that was really romantic very true yeah
because I think the whole idea of I mean
just were you I put out getting to 29
years world gets an album from me um no
I think part of it is like I key I don't
know is it Cammy I know this is gonna be
way too serious but I was like um I
think part of it is like like his
community you want to kind of be in
control right and like when you get like
publicly humiliated like that like
that's what it felt like I could like at
other guys were just like who cares the
story was fun to do it like I was like
that at all like really traumatized for
a long time you have now do you have a
bad set on it no it was interesting
because i looked i couldn't look at the
tape for years yam and then when I
finally looked at the tape is like two
of the people gave me fours right you
know which is the highest right yeah and
to a neighbor gave me toos uh oh I was
like and that kind of sums up my career
like people are like really into me or
like next exhale i think i talked about
it's never like all to the girls are all
fours across when I was like two and a
half years in I auditioned for more
three and a half years in addition for
Last Comic Standing huh and I didn't get
it and it was like [ __ ] Kindler was
like no you're not funny Teixeira was
like no you're not funny did they sure
y'all don't like Nina wasn't on TV thank
God so right but that's just think about
it though and that was on TV yeah yeah
but it's just funny like cuz giralda was
like yeah I think you could be funny I
think so weird situates yeah under the
situation is so dry I was one yet didn't
go on TV
especially with that sure they set you
up for a fall I think a little bit they
have your weight online for what ya any
weight on line did you know this was
like a book they sent you up yeah but it
was so weak who were the people judging
you I don't even remember is like some
guy Toya Jackson is yeah it wasn't even
the judge and the comedian the beat me
like all I wanted to do with interview
this guy Tim rose who doesn't even do
comedy wasn't even like serious about
yeah yeah and one of those things that
stuck out in your brain that you I don't
know just off the top my head I'm yeah
I've never really talked about it that
much and sorry to bring your podcast
down but uh when I think back I was like
I and also anyway i did this bit i had
this very long closing bit about skiing
it's like four and a half minutes and so
you only get like 90 seconds so i tried
to squeeze it all Yeah Yeah right I'm
yes I get the rhythm of that thing and I
don't know I was it was pretty like that
felt bad so let me ask you this after
you did it did it affect you getting
back on stage well I've always suffered
from stage fright so that kind of pushed
it up like another level of like oh
what's the worst thing that can happen I
don't know humiliated in front of the
country you know what I mean everyone is
like so it's like that so I was dealing
with that as well so yeah that's uh
that's rough yes funny because you you
ask the question no I say it's wrong he
does that yeah you know two people
drowning can't save each other way it's
just do that in every situation every
beautiful baby to be playing against
each other you uh because you're in was
it I am comic that you were in and you
get that story but don't know you guys
were on the road in that you were like
in some like Florida crazy Florida oh no
no you're thinking of I am road calm I
am road comedy that was it yeah don't
worry old you guys in that gig upstate
washing and yeah that was just like a
little documentary about kind of all the
steps of doing a road gig yeah Randy a
car that they I was trying to get the
free food that dry unit right absolutely
horrible you know turn out they've jelly
not jelly jello wrestling yeah reacts
right was great was great it was my
question is the [ __ ] show I'm just like
hagan stand-up comedy and just the value
on it too it's like okay we might be
able to get some people in here by yanks
winning it for everybody yeah somebody
once said it's like that stand-up is
like a great way to sell drinks and
fried cheese right like so many big
yellow sticks oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so
that was like a version of that but it
never stops getting humiliating I don't
think right really I don't know really
maybe I think amy schumer's like I'm
being humiliated every night yeah it
does i guess I'm just saying I I almost
every time I've had something cool
happen the next day something really
humiliating just recently like for
instance like I the same day I found out
I got a writing job somewhere I
auditioned for club with a bunch of open
mic errs when it was I mean can we just
slow down son I want any club is but do
you mean no division audition and an
open mic and for club um to see if I
could get regular work there right at
like in LA and I okay um and uh it was
an open mic and I and I was I remember
somebody who was coming into my do them
like head open for me on the road like
four months earlier and I do it I do not
get past this club because there's like
to but I'm going with a bunch of people
who've only been in comedy two years and
then you know and then you get
afterwards you get like advice you know
and it's like you know what but you know
here's the humbling thing is like
somebody was ready like you were rushing
and I'm like yeah I was because I was
humiliated about having to audition at
an open mic when I thought that I had
gotten past that and I realizing oh the
only time you go past it it's like when
they asked you to come and deuce like
like I could have like I I did the worst
decision either you don't do that or you
do it you don't do the other one where
you're like half acid you know what I
mean like you know you're young but I
dancing shoes I agree with that yeah
like we just say no we're put on the
dancing shoes you can't put on one
dancing shoe and woke a shamed you know
like and you know what I should go back
there again and do it again but a bio
point is like even after like I did when
I did the half hour the next day i did a
club or
for four people we did coming central
prism is representing the next day I did
a club for four people and I just they
couldn't speak English and I look hurt
yeah looked hurt can I speak to that
because course two things 1i was talking
to do you know the Sklar brothers their
twin yeah sometimes yeah they they said
that like like it's almost like trying
to climb Mount Everest like there's so
many things there's dead bodies and you
fall back and I always thought that was
a great analogy but but what we were
saying is like I always feel like my
career a little bit is like if I could
make it as a sound it would go like this
uh-huh that's exactly right exactly I've
had it so many times I'm like okay
haha but on a loop cuz it is just go
back and forth so it's all the way i'm
still doing ah stuff so there is right
oh yeah there's still like okay just not
and i just enough to not kill yourself
but yeah I mean it's yeah this kind of
but it's gonna it's also like almost
like the funnier way you know like if it
was a whole tragic it was like oh it's
all the time right right then it
wouldn't be as funny then you'd be a
delusional mess yeah like it makes you
realize there's a book that just came
out could the comedian's you know about
this brown no just came out last week
and it starts like in vaudeville and
goes right up to kind of like pies a
good name it's excellent it's excellent
all right it's by this guy craziest name
in the world cliff nesterov I'm gonna
say the game wow what do this is like
rough what it is like a goat like Wayne
ghostwriting am now a try to puzzle
through the itches you with like a bigot
Rowley Mustang in Canada but but he is
very much into the story of like these
comedians that do and then all on our
time so is that there's a lot of that
recurring theme of a lot of people
making it and then falling off right so
like right from the get-go like in radio
in nightclubs you know those every facet
of the college sorry if you're
interested in any I would don't work
yeah that's so sad to know it's a it's
it is kind of sad it is kind of I mean I
guess but it was fascinating like right
through the whole the whole thing it's
you know it's like it's one of these
everybody knows those stories and he
wrote a whole book about them it's like
what's the secret then that's what goes
on you use those as cautionary tales or
what do you know I think he's just
basically saying it's like it's a this
is what we've created here in America
and they've said this there's gonna
marry go round of like you jump on when
you're starting and then you get thrown
off for you hold on in your Baba but you
know and yea even him dat the end was
like that was kind of weird the way that
all ended you know when that was a huge
couldn't be the bigger comedian rubab ho
yeah I gave me at the end where he kept
going in the night you know is she's
like ninety skilled reading cue cards
like barely could you know right because
he couldn't well there's you guys like I
jump on anymore yeah yeah yeah well that
was like you i heard story like the
Ronnie Dangerfield who's who was on oh
the Dangerfield stuff some made
especially the pre Rodney you know he
was so comedian before he was right yeah
yeah that's a made-up name yeah all of
that stuff's in there it's really fun
why really fun well I fine i just think
it's like he had a story like that were
apparently there's a story that wasn't
as was third wife whatever was was
putting your he had an earpiece in and
she would tell him the jokes from
backstage when he got really much older
really rotten stage and he would recite
the jumble of that don't know yeah why i
love that man lifted to have a walk
hello you mean have a life hell yeah
wife there's a funnier comic just giving
me material you know gavagan's wife
writes a lot for him yeah they write
together yeah yeah that's pretty good
team this way yeah yeah honey do you
want to start running together and
arielle he's just laughing I got no I
that's why I go dates tinder dates my
guess is i guess they're like can we
write what have you notice about what
i'm wearing well you made a joke on a
date that way you mentioned this once
before but oh that's what that one color
i plagiarized a joke on a date no no
jobs about that i'm michelle she
plagiarized he made a joke he made a
joke on a day like in passing and the
girl next day tweeted it on our twitter
oh there was that i talked about that on
the podcast yeah but I'm saying it fits
what we're talking well there's another
thing that I did which was the lamest
thing where I went on a girl out with a
girl and we're sure we were talking
about sex or something and I was like
weirdest place I've ever had sex to the
end of the bed and I tell you this or so
it is a bit you do no no go ahead go
ahead no but then she goes wait isn't
that a bit from friends and I was like
yeah I just ripped off a friends episode
plotline to try to impress her I
actually admire her that she would be
that yeah eligible not [ __ ] me yeah why
could it make the yeah we show the dog
would love that veterans anyway the now
to know it was friends or you just said
I'd like I was saying and I knew what I
was doing
yes Crais I was crate I'm like Jaguar
lately of dating wait a min oh wait a
minute have you done that before that
worked before no I don't know I did it
once before I think it's where I tried
to get white I used someone else's joke
maybe was like Mike warrants while I was
trying to hook up with a girl and it
worked yeah and then after that I did it
again that I stopped doing it after that
didn't work I was like what's not am I
don't do it on stage or try to make
money off it it's not the same thing
it's crazy Mary oh you look horrified
shunts believe is real orange but maybe
was Norman I don't know who was but I
remember I you I ripped off a french
joke to try to get laid one night and I
don't know who was maybe Andy hey I've
really no idea but then after I did that
that was those basically the end of it
so what do you what year did you start
doing stand-up two thousand six or seven
Wow ok so I'm up like nine years and two
months in and did you were you like
funny in high school were you that kind
yeah it was like--there funny so
obnoxious like you went to a theater
colleges why wasn't I college but whoa
things just got risky happened here you
went to theatre for college that's what
you said you went to uh no to college or
theater but I know I was a theater kid
in high school so it was you sing do you
yeah yes I can sing um I do a little
like nippon please don't know he'll do
it I do a little more than I do look
we're not coming internet may come one
of those could be yeah I did that what
about you how old are we now don't turn
it back on and I'm a little bored I
don't like mini Mayer and we're all
trying to be Mara now how're you feeling
like when you started uh no III don't
know I was I think I was like funny but
I get obnoxious like we'll get me like I
wasn't really funny I was like were you
like hyperactive yeah I mean I just want
attention i mean i don't think i was
genuinely killing me I just wanted Emily
funnier kids knighted I just said like
give me an example of a musical you were
in the hue I was in pajama game huh
Joseph
10 or three blows my mind blows my mind
you knowing you and we were here just a
few times yeah yeah your act is so not
whoa Johnny game esque John and Jim
Jefferies musical guy I mean he was
really guy really that's what I heard he
was a theater guy i was in gypsy i
played a new zein gypsy really yeah it's
not a surprise at all do you have you g
what was your wine do you remember it
extra extra something that was hey not
really I mean that's kind of what you do
man it's amazing it sent you up his hand
out papers yeah I was in that and then I
was in some other pureed well this is
big news you were just in a [ __ ] TV
show you were in a limitless I was in
limitless I'll just share could I play
wait a bit and everything so yeah man it
man i'm dead waiting generally you don't
know what you put in a bunch they have
been a bunch of stuff but not limitless
not limitless don't worry have a time
you'll be this is a huge this is a huge
TV show based on a somewhat successful
movie that's gonna be kind get paid
today you should hook up as I was saying
that I'm like a frozen know you're in a
really funny Geico commercial now yes
but Kenny Rogers yes was it like working
with that guy it was easy he said we
talked a lot about it's a good day very
good guy very good guy um we talked a
lot about the Eagles cuz I didn't know
he was so instrumental in that band I
didn't either yeah until I saw that four
hour documentary about the eagle I
didn't know he had anything to do with
you yeah neither did I so we talked
about that and he's a is he was like
start out as a jazz bass player stand-up
bass right Wow like yeah so you know we
got one from like like kind of acid rock
to country too right right right well
there's that show there's that song he
has a big lebowski it's amazing yeah I
just dropped in to see what you wish my
conditions and not familiar with that
movie it's good yes haha um yeah he's uh
that's crazy get to meet him he works
pretty good for how old he is about to
retire he's about to retire this was
gonna be his last year really really
he's like I like Mike I like hearing
that you don't hear anybody retire ever
like apparently what's a who retired
Jack Nicholson retired right yeah this
is done yeah you can't read scripts
anymore and
memorized oh really and Gene Hackman
retire cheat hack and gene wilder and
Wilder yeah he may come back though I
heard what what no that's not true is I
hurry maybe come back for Spielberg
movie well if you like to be in some
sound of like angelic roll or something
yeah right yeah that [ __ ] [ __ ] I
think we would be happy that interview
they had that 92 watch gene Wilder know
so yeah yeah no I haven't seen it what
why did he see how serious of a guy he
is considering how hilarious he is yeah
because they're like talking about you
know the state of he talked about now
state of movies and something that he's
like I think it's discreet he's very
like proper and very but why did you
think it's disgraceful I think I think
like your short skirt like you know II
yeah curse word eagle' exams and the
lank the language a like manner maybe a
little yeah very nice had a vision of
like like Gene Wilder like like with
like like a shawl like watching Magic
Mike and being more huh oh that's kind
of what it was yeah what's he retired
but he's nobody ever talked like you
think Morgan Freeman he's awesome but
he's like only about 75 or something I
don't know yeah and I think about that
point i would just retire I would just
go and live on a boat somewhere that's
why we'll never be like Morgan Freeman
cuz we think about that I know I know I
have as much cash as my yeah because he
doesn't think about shouldn't do I know
somebody's done right- what could I quit
you know that's not a good thought to
have no it's not but it happens I guess
he's one of those guys that like I I
just met worked for him and he has a
whole team of people I guess a lot of
these at about these famous celebrities
do like my mom I say the whole makeup
for him how she did yeah she was on
movie with with like him in Virginia mad
so some movie didn't do very well but
she was because she was I was a Rob
Reider movie I think she was like makeup
person I'd she was assistant makeup on
it she kind of didn't she decided to get
out of that and just teaches me output
and she interests name is Cole shih tzus
yeah it was cool well that's not yeah
she owes should i what's my mom yeah I
don't know she was all right I don't
know I think what's wrong because Morgan
Freeman listens to this ya know
it was nice apparently Kenan was nice I
don't know but you see you worked when
you start at you're doing do you start
at New York right so you did the start
out of New York City had like crazy
story with sports and the strip or some
well it was this is really [ __ ] bad
raspy I know the ideas is what bad
things the dumbest is what i did is what
I did we don't want to I was at the
comic strip was my home club still there
in New York still barely holding on
right like of all the three clubs
there's the improv catch a rising star
in the comics shredder comics you're
believing that last man standing I'm
shocked yeah catch was like God couldn't
that place was limousines lined up
around the brain oh wow my god dustin
off and walking in the people i was in
creep really gained like the whole thing
and i wasn't like a big were you a big
cocaine guy no not at all not at all
once in a while people after shows would
say do you want to do some coconuts like
it's just like hey you were funny yeah
yeah that hasn't happened it was like a
30 year nobody can afford that just like
now so you want a cigarette me but
people would do that with like Benson
with pot and stuff like that right is
that happened to you where people like
oh I don't happy bows and I remember
what I was drinking on samurai was
because I quit then I was I remember one
weekend I was relapsing but I would
always try to people would be let's
smoke weed but I bi haha let me know if
you guys have any pills or coke like I
made it very specific from what I would
say on stage and then somebody be like
we'd know my god want this [ __ ] [ __ ] I
mean really sure you're not a roadie are
you showing that love it have you gotten
orbited smoke weed people's anyone with
smoke weed after the show was like nah I
don't smoke weed or anything like yeah
yeah I'm all right it's like a weird
exchange yeah right right right yeah
yeah very intimate thing to do with
someone I think did with total stranger
yeah it's easier at cell so anyway so
we're at the comic strip day we had the
something called the Broadway show
League which is a softball league double
play in Central Park and so we would
have liked the comic strip would go up
against you know the if this cash from
aveda or something like now when this
right right basically you know not the
most athletic guys and although there
dancers you know so we come of those
guys some other guys were amazing and
they had some of the crew geyser of
course and say and we where you go
anyway so one day I think we're playing
the improv and I'm out of course in
right field trying to where you do the
least damage right that's why was I was
a kid somebody and I don't know how to
describe this but Central Park is like
five fields and they're all they all
kind of share deep center field like a
sort of like a big part commenters about
yes so there's five diamonds all around
one big circle yeah of course I'm
playing into shallow somebody hits the
ball over my head i miss play it i take
a step in and like I know that's going
over my head I go right ahead I run I
grab the ball I turn I whip it to third
base wrong field literally the wrong
field and then I just kind of looked to
the right or like and later everyone is
just has their hands up like comics
although there was as like and the guy
who caught it on the other field was
like I don't even know I was so panicked
I know what I mean trying to uh who's on
his team oh well it was I think you know
Jeff Garlin and Joe bolster bear laundry
you know what I mean it was like those
comic strip guys from back then and I
was like that Seinfeld episode where I
think they play a Broadway show they do
yeah yay there is in a week yeah yeah
yeah Rochelle Rochelle that's like a
fake brova show yeah yeah yeah they play
they play softball against them in the
show I'm sure that's the exact so that
was that was one of my most oh that's
funny my much you Millie 80 Hey Ya Ya
like things I did well they're like
we're gonna bench you for a couple games
there Wayne yeah and then I just had I
ran the 1985 New York Marathon oh nice
but I was great but I couldn't I vote
and I retired from running the day after
that run sense i mean i still play
basketball but i want what happened well
there was a comedian I think I want to
say bill McCarty aye
this right you used to say that running
is the only sport that combines a
mind-numbing boredom with pure physical
agony like it's just the worst like
possibly do that I hope that's right it
is the worst it is the worst so but i
did because it was like the running
craze but yeah so i didn't i didn't rain
or anything like that i was just in a
lot of pain for the whole rice bun train
for the marathon but i was just too
boring i was like i knew i was gonna do
it i knew i was like whatever the pain
must have been pretty okay okay i'm
starting to run again named hard to
believe oh I've inspired by Sean's wife
lat Sean but tell but yeah I me get the
ipod go and then it feels like you're
getting better right know if we're cut
like yours terrible so was being I don't
know people get people do have that what
is that called writers I yeah yeah I
never I've never come anywhere near it
serious marielle have you ever gotten
runner's high when you running yeah yeah
marielle runs i would love to have that
i would love to have it it's the
endorphins in your brain that get
release so that you it numbs you to the
running right
you have you run a marathon yeah you
almost ran the marathon a couple years
13.1 miles that's really impressive well
that's really 26 miles 26.2 get it right
oh my got a right jerk what isn't 6mo
too late how are you running I was like
I think it was eleven thousand three
hundred and something that's pretty good
five hours 13 minutes 50 people were
there 17,000 that's pretty good the few
thousand didn't make it so I beat a
couple thousand people I would just
think I can I walk this even walking it
I would be like Fox visto it's so stupid
it was so stupid but I got a one joke
out of it can I do the joke ok this was
a joke it's like so I did the New York
Marathon which is the easiest of all the
marathon of courses cuz it's 17 miles
when you hit the wall is the exact
moment you cross over into the South
Bronx and then for the rest of the race
you're just fleeing racist but I aliens
there yeah yeah me I rashim opera is
after you yeah yeah that's a 485 that
was everybody like yeah right i said yes
it was a joke and a fact at the same
it's a fact so uh that was so people
used to really get paid in cocaine back
then no oh well hey it's so funny in
that book yeah at the comedians I don't
know I'm pushing this book cuz i've been
reading they like overton Rick Overton
talks about doing shows with the club
owner was like I'll pay you on cocaine
and he was like sure I'd never happened
to me I mean I've had club owners not
pay me or you know what yeah short me
your stuff like that but I've never ever
had anyone do anything like that hey you
encode but I like the not paying is
always brute I just had that happen in
Atlantic City you know the comedy stop
in Atlantic City that Richard min eerie
me no no that's gonna pay you this is
Bob Bob they didn't pay you didn't pay
you then pay he closed the club two
weeks later he's like all we're gonna
pay it uh everybody's like oh it takes a
while to get paid and then somebody goes
ham that happened that's happened to me
yeah I had oh yeah at a club my i feel i
will mention it because of my agency
like they made it up to me they kind of
just like eh forget commission the next
couple but the guy totally gypped me
like 300 for our bucks so sucks yeah do
you feel like that's a racial slur
against [ __ ]
cease when you say that that's what I
comes from I just carry my in this new
world I don't want to get I tell you
what I'll just a weird eyes when they're
able to buy a house to meet about Mike
all right then they go doubles down he
doubled down get have a meeting in a 10
on a hill is not every bird I am I gonna
be in a blog I used to I I Brown got
really annoyed me because I made fun of
gypsies once on facebook so he posted
[ __ ] mental every every four days he
posted a new part of a gypsy movie like
a famous gypsy movie I was kidding but
this yeah yeah really oh you know Wayne
turning on the blacks and then it just
got I know yes i was thinking more
hispanic yeah so so wrong if you don't
know South Bronx all right well broccoli
that's the only non gentrify level place
cuz no but now that's not true that's
not true and you know there's just all
thing that the big buildings going up
really oh yeah Wayne heard what a
high-rise I they were trying to do it
for a while they were gonna call it so
bro did you hear that no yeah so bro
it's gonna happen it's just so close to
manhattan yeah i am everything to happen
every lot most you know you know what's
the newest one is his bed-stuy bed-stuy
Brooklyn when yeah well I i also talked
about on stay well my dad used to
threaten to move us there if we were bad
as kids and now it's like AIT's and now
it now they're like hey come on by well
that's what ever they just pushed um all
the crime to camden Giuliani is like it
just push it to Jersey you know is that
what it was kind of well I mean I give
you a go i know this was a neat little
car this is interested where crime went
down and i get there are other parts
around it like in jersey the crime would
be hearing rumors they just give him one
way bus tickets to florida they'd like
get on the bus let's say her too yes
miss and crime and all that kind of
their just like get out of New York it's
a wild west method of doing things you
and who could we believe like 4i got so
messed up in ya for the guys are crazy
device you know I lived in florida right
did you yeah are we offending you right
now well I just feel like I'm right here
oh my how are you in for a person I'm
I'm not a hologram I have real feeling
I'm a real you can tell you grow up for
a half my childhood yes it's often yeah
I got wherever here to where Harry back
in town we're in Florida it's believe it
or not a place called plantation that's
in that alley right outside Fort
Lauderdale you're like part of the
problem yeah and not only they live in
plantation but I lived I went to south
plantation high I went to the less
progressive part of plantation in the
deep south Oh spelled plantation but you
got out of Florida yeah yeah you go
after that did in New York 20 new dig
that up no don't want to end my you to
study acting and then always one which
school did you go to am I you you were a
theater guy too yeah but not I did I was
never in the pajama game Peter guys talk
[ __ ] in the theater guys bros u bye guys
and dolls ok what school are you in
Adler that allure yeah yeah you were
like an intense Stan's house key guy
yeah yeah yeah what's like real oh
you're like a brand oh yes thank you for
knowing all of that the Stella was still
teaching when I went there really taught
me she she's like I'm done she was like
I cracked her just like who is this
clown that I have to dealing with Marlon
Brando just 15 years ago jokester walks
at man haha yeah so she was at the annum
when she came in the room we had to
stand up real yep yeah because she was
that famous by that no that was just
part of this oh no not stand just like
the president Danna yeah and you
couldn't have like water or coffee or
anything like that and oh wow she was
she was really good i really liked her
ex-husband this guy harold clurman he
came in yeah yeah okay parda this is all
crazy group theatre stuff but yeah so
that was a good and but even then I was
like kind of auditioning or going to
like being in the room with her Stella
Adler well was she looked really old to
be honest you will she was all but she
was pretty that and she was video
in a lot of it so I know there's like a
giver [ __ ] money yeah now I don't
know whatever happened those videos as
I'm curious about that but she at I and
looking back I think it was a little too
young and naive to really get super bowl
full as I was like I was into Neil Simon
and she's into like check off and Ibsen
you know what I mean kind of a little
different mentality of like what what I
why I would wanted to be on stage and so
uh you still taking any from that class
yeah once in a while once a while I'm
acting I was like you know just about
clarity of intention and she always she
had a great quote she said your talent
is in your choices ok and she said and I
was a well that's interesting out the
people just talented like know
specifically what choices you're just
out of all the horrible choices are made
what if I play this one like Jamaica get
your talent yeah then when you in the
americas got talent a super bowl
commercial what choices were you making
then when Howard Stern was hosing you
down a fire calm down guy who plays a
civil service worker and every acting
jobs every boy that's true guy who's not
long enough to play the real life
version of that job but somehow could
booger baby that's smart enough to play
an actual chef I love this TV crowd
there was a chef civil service I don't
know that chef but yeah well you were
common I was a cop and I was a secure
was a cop security guard oh and a
carpenter yeah whoever's killed first
and like a batman movie Steve O'Brien
joke Jesus it's okay don't worry about
what happened was there lies your brains
like a horse of course of course does he
do that and then you and then you sir
doin stand up while you were at MIT I
started I mean I did a one-man show when
I was there Wow and and and then cuz i
started believe it or not in high school
doing ventriloquism okay yeah oh really
you know i know that sounds humiliated i
actually no no I mean I was I believed
it on board what oh really I was like
look great flavor god I'm like yeah yeah
I could be you doing the puppet move in
high school well
dan had puppets in the beginning my dad
and marionettes creepiest let's creep
your love that I love so you really had
a puppet I wasn't dummy you heard Buford
Buford that's a great day that's the
Florida kicking in yes Jesus the Florida
and as I've said before I took him to my
senior prom with I had a date oh man
also performed its senior prom are you
serious yes that's the law reform what
is the most horrifying that's worth
majid being thorough later on oh yeah I
went with the ventriloquist what did you
say that no he brought his dummy to prom
I was supposed to lose my virginity that
night but no I guess my my date and his
date had other plans did you get away
that I don't know I of course I did has
it been drilled how cream of you mean
getting later than just slowly the doll
high five are you doing that are you
that was shockingly I was a virgin when
I graduated high school even with the
pitcher like my junior prom was the word
this girl invited me there Susan I
should get a bit about this Beatrice we
got the limo but we tried to be fun and
dresses 80s characters was really stupid
all right again I was like trying to be
funny and I was like [ __ ] hearing I
got no I got in the [ __ ] limo first
thing she says is like well just to let
you know um just found out my pastor
killed himself so we're gonna have to
deal with that hey this was the first
thing she's yet first thing she says so
this is a promise n this was a junior
prom and then we went to Caroline's to
go see [ __ ] re Spears right after she
told me her pastor killed himself and I
just got hammered yeah it was like a
worse i did not get away story from last
week not much just James for yeah just
we gave my a Raymond Carver [ __ ]
story
yes right no my dad no legs we were you
from New Jersey Rutherford yeah oh man
Westchester me that East Rutherford no r
other hand the regular rubber a horse I
wrestled in east rutherford look at this
there we go wait a minute you were in
the pajama game and you're Restless and
then I want to do the Sun Hawk trip
there's also wrestling around behind
scenes in pajama game as well right well
that's yeah a while ago 33 now for sure
with the music for the picture up Dan I
forget I know who wrote if I remember we
met I know gypsy Jeffrey Adler from
fiddler when we did that name honey we
met him he was still alive they're
redoing that Bitler officious now
theaters it's all just a theater talk we
just are no at certain points this way
engine starts interviewing you about
your trial I'm curious let's cedar I
don't know much Ivan right how much of a
dancer the pajama game uh here we go
Richard Adler Jerry Ross oh so what that
law was a blur yeah did he do said War
two no i don't know maybe that was jerry
orbach no that's too thick if it's the
[ __ ] one otter actor you don't need a
design I don't know you know that right
when he died you doing sighs yeah very
orbit he's no ice yeah I forgot even
lose your luggage area or bracha [ __ ]
jokes a minute i'm free wait for done it
you know I'm donating my body to science
when I die for real yeah because I'm so
desperate for attention and I want some
young USC student working on a cadaver
go and wait a minute what's this kindly
x5 were you you were Maxwell's just one
episode who were you on the air smells
believe it or not lady guy named Wayne
Federman although not Wayne Federman
really they just it was just ran down I
random it was a part written with me in
mind by David Duchovny it was like a I
played a producer who was shadowing
Mulder and Scully to write a movie about
these two go that's funny and in the
movie you're gonna watch this episode
yeah it's going really into the X X
Files and like
guess it's called Hollywood ad and
within the movie tay leone and Garry
Shandling place color and Mulder so I
remember Holly what's funny Hollywood ad
oh cuz you because you're friends with
Garry Shandling see you that I knew
Garry Shandling from the Larry Sanders
Show and then the company knew me from
stand-up so Hollywood ad yeah so uh so
anyway yeah so I played yeah so it was
great i played that and i actually had
audition for the role of Wayne Federman
that's [ __ ] annoying that's funny or
the story I think we talked about was my
guess where Jermaine Fowler was like
auditioning for something and he saw
like looking for a Hannibal Buress type
so you just called Hannibal and Hannibal
showed up and booked it right you know
what weird stuff at all right well we
gotta wrap this thing up let's do it
Wayne why so much for coming on very
welcome i hope i don't know just what
what yeah we haven't been talking what
wha to get the chronicles of Fetterman
on your website on itunes and amazon
yeah amazon yeah is there anything else
right Alan oh um uh yeah i mean i have
my own podcast can I talk about that
yeah sure that melted yeah of course
yeah that's okay with a woman 25 years
my junior named Aaron magothy nice and
it's called human conversation if you
guys just have you adjusted two of us
just till this is hauling it just 22
doing it right to have that before the
podcast living it was scary yeah
comfortable is uncomfortable yeah you
wanna promote anything thank you for
having me on by the way thank you know
I'm glad you guys I love it next time
what have you walked in there's just a
guy with like a ventriloquist dummy
regular it's a whole new block but um no
I mean just check my website I love my
dates and stuff on there and yeah i'm
the same thing just check sean donnelly
dumb I don't think um I wasn't done
dancer and buy my album oof marielle I
do anything to pop no nothing Mary oh
and providing Marriott yeah Tom Lewis oh
yeah but you're married to show
donnelly hema that that's a credit so
we're raising money for cure for the Tom
so please just do it i'm doing right i'm
just jokin I've got East I hope stops
he's a producer I would I had the
running bit that he was dying okay he's
gonna keep it going doesn't cancer Mary
all dan just does that cuz he's a
[ __ ] idiot wow we're really landing
on some acrimony from this okay but
seriously donated Tom's fun all right
have a good one guys dick
thank you for listening to the my dumb
friends podcast here's where you can see
our host performing live this week Sean
Donnelly is performing in and around New
York City go to Sean Donnelly comedy
calm to check out his show dates and
times also go to Sean Donnelly calm to
check out his album that came out this
fall dan st. germain is going to be in
maryland this weekend on December
nineteenth he will be at the big timing
comedy at rhody joe's show and salisbury
maryland and on the twentieth of
december he will be at the cellar door
in Frederick Maryland then it's on to
New York City for Dan go to dan st.
germain dot net to check out his
schedule as well as to check out his
album which is available there to buy or
download they make great Christmas gifts
so check them out thank you everybody
for your support over the year as we're
coming down to the end of the year if
you would care to throw us a couple
bucks we would greatly appreciate it go
to my dumb friends podcast tumblr com
and scroll around in there and you will
see a donation button there for paypal
so safe and secure donation via paypal
at my dumb friends podcast tumblr com
send us a note we'd love to read it and
read it on our mailbag episodes send it
to my dumb friends podcast at gmail com
thank you have a great week
for other cool comedy podcasts go to all
things comedy com yes we're a part of
the all things comedy network we're one
of many great comedy podcasts that's all
things comedy dot com our opening and
closing song is called Mary the boxer by
Phil Pickens you can find out more about
Phil at Phil Pickens com
this you can't hold me you
nah
No
me
you